well Johnny Cash do you [ __ ] as
a remembrance maybe you were thinking of
doing a line of coke
now you gotta do one now you gotta
commit now you gotta [ __ ] commit
what's the story Lisa yeah what's the
story the story is that what what I'm
about to be [ __ ] up I'm not Robert I'd
[ __ ] sit there you watch ESPN all day
you believe what they talk about you
gotta get your [ __ ] together all right
yeah I love ESPN I know I never seen no
I think you just sit they be [ __ ] yeah
and when they talk about stocks and
bonds well they always the markets know
that football's getting started an
elephant I only had the first preseason
game so that means three more weeks so I
got a call last weekend okay my friend
cause it was hey it's Griffin's 13th
birthday what are you doing next Tuesday
I don't know he goes come with us as the
family celebrate Griffin's birthday
where are we going he goes Oxnard the
Raiders are playing the Dallas Cowboys
and we're gonna go up there and my Mike
the baby gets carsick
thank [ __ ] god better ground up there
like an idiot did you see what happened
no it was a fight in pre-season
oh yeah well idiots won and the fighters
have you been to an open game I heard
that's pretty crazy
yeah you don't even know they listen la
[ __ ] baseball games people getting
concussions yeah you might already
they're [ __ ] savages they're on
probation they don't let you in there
unless you're on probation on parole and
their interviews like you raped a
grandmother something [ __ ] crazy they
don't like it they don't let normal
people to [ __ ] Raider game you got to
show up with a [ __ ] mental health
counselor yes put somebody a gun it's
[ __ ] ridiculous you might as well
watch that [ __ ] at the house I love the
Raiders I love watching what I love the
tradition I get it yeah but that don't
mean you gotta go to a [ __ ] game and
gets that well it's not even I mean it's
fun life but if you want if you really
want to watch the game I feel like it's
better at home cuz whenever I've been to
a game I'm always looking at the friggin
monitor anyways but you go you watch I
love it I love live performances yeah
but there's an extremely you sit things
oh how much longer my
he's gotten [ __ ] in the ass I gotta
pay 200 for a ticket 22 for a hot dog a
scarf a pig [ __ ] enough I used to go to
games never 15 [ __ ] bucks
$2.00 for a hot dog you got a diet soda
whatever it was three hours that's it
now you can't go to a Laker game man you
can't do anything
I'm taking my uncle to the Dodgers
September 22nd
I want a Subway sandwich those
[ __ ] yeah and they had some code
and I flew it in and they charged me
double and it was shitty tickets but I
had already told him so I was already
committed so I wasn't gonna tell him the
subway sucks dick no I pulled it up and
I [ __ ] and drop the yardstick and got
decent ticket for me and my 74 year old
on oh good I'm gonna take them and I
gotta sit there for nine innings because
he's Cuban I can't act like the regular
Gentiles in LA they go to a game for six
innings and go oh we got to get out of
here Starbucks is closing you know
that's a big Starbucks closed without
you making the last [ __ ] nightcap did
you record a minor league baseball in
your kid I was a couple times and it's
always a ton of fun
and my parents were happier cuz until I
was like seven or eight I never made it
past like the second inning cuz kids I
was there it was fun before and let me
sat down I got bored but Mike my parents
were taking us to like I had a birthday
party once it looked a triple-a game and
it was cheap and it was fun and when
you're a kid you don't really know the
difference it's all baseball listen man
you take a kid to a baseball game after
two innings they don't care of Jesus
from the [ __ ] ball right a stadium
and bother people and throw peanuts to
saying you only come back to pick up two
more let me get two more hours you
coming back here two more hours and you
run for [ __ ] and your parents get upset
but that's what those things are for I
just like glowing my parents with the
Aqueduct Racetrack
okay in New York there was a bunch of
kids playing two-hand touch football
every time you wanted to you just said
goodbye see on the way out I'll be out
here playing to entice football with
these animals from [ __ ] the Bronx
that sounds like fun
sure why not
why not so what else that's all you got
for me you have a plateau at the gym
what's going on with you yeah here like
[ __ ] I don't have depressed well yeah
because when you start losing weight you
like seeing the numbers going down and
I've been doing good but I don't know
what it is III I've been at this little
plateau and I told you I haven't been
[ __ ] at all sorry for the girls out
there but I got some someone said
probiotics help that so I'm trying to do
that and then all backed up huh yeah I
don't know what it is just gummy a bell
no well [ __ ] kill you don't push
don't do none tonight you stop at CVS
and just ask them I want this [ __ ] that
sends out everything pushes all the
animals Steve Simone said there's
something called like a psyllium fiber
or something you can buy that it's
really good what does he do oh he tries
to mixes it with one that pushes
everything but you may have to stick a
finger up your muffler and loosen stuff
you might have said [ __ ] hummus it's
that hummus it's not the whole [ __ ] you
and that [ __ ] hummus how much those
[ __ ] Arabians they make that [ __ ] so
when you drink it with coca-cola it
tightens up in your [ __ ] that's the
plan the [ __ ] killer sucks yeah
that's right I don't need that [ __ ]
that's why that's why you climbed up
think of what that [ __ ] is it's [ __ ]
spackle its Arabian [ __ ] speck
advance if they use on the huts they no
[ __ ] you [ __ ] people jump up and down
like a bunch of [ __ ] mutts
that's what you got stop that [ __ ]
that's why you're backed up maybe you
know that's all [ __ ] hummus tighten
those chickpeas and that [ __ ]
toenails whatever they putting that [ __ ]
disgusting what's happening LA
hootenanny in the [ __ ] house we
happy to be here Todd at my main man
the Greek Papadakis what's happening
fellas do we just around somebody come
in we're playing this weekend I have to
straight from you I know right have to
fellow I love it
nice little [ __ ] place [ __ ] yeah got
a great song can you guys go upstairs
yeah we got a nice salad couple
cocktails there's always a couple of
holes hanging out so sad mate you're
sitting there you don't want to watch
shark tank [ __ ] it get a quaalude go
down it the feather will swing some dick
take a chance Columbus Day where do you
get a quaalude you can't you gotta go to
[ __ ] neighborhoods I got one at the
house but it's like a half a dud some of
the game to me in San Jose so one night
I was home like cracked a half like the
skin pop it nothing happened I popped
the other half I don't know what is it
still called a quaalude or if they
changed the name to them they'd change
they change the name and everything like
that
I want to doctor them having surgery
over 26 he gave me a prescription for
Vikings he doesn't have Ike there's no
more they call him north coast now
uh-huh what's the [ __ ] difference I'm
gonna I'm gonna be backed up likely for
three [ __ ] no those things are the
worst I don't know how people get
addicted to psycho so codeine and
Tylenol holy [ __ ] those things codeine
is great and that's what's back in you
but no no I know I all being the [ __ ]
hummus I only I only did it when it was
mine I got bronchitis from smoking hash
at your house that's right and they gave
me coding and I could see what people
liked it because it was it was me what
happened it's just like it's like kind
of like we a warmer weed but then you
don't you like you're still kind of
conscious you can still walk around you
sure yeah and I didn't take that much I
just took the drinking yeah it's a how
do you smoke not to look drink some
codeine you smoke some cigarettes you're
off and running check that's at the old
port of Ricans did I don't think you're
doing jumping jacks yeah hallucinate
they used to do all that [ __ ] in the
seventies with the [ __ ] codeine you
want to vent this
yeah you drank it you smoked something
the next thing you know you were seeing
Martians I don't [ __ ] know I'm just I
was in a coding person I don't know
there wasn't even any UFOs in the 70s
all that project please
but coding get closer to the microphone
side project Bluebook now they what's in
iqual I don't know Boston I think is
that's what the rappers like the in
Houston we were talking about they'd the
chopped and screwed style that slowed
down
that's right syrup that's reducing that
people may claim otherwise but I always
read that it was it started know what is
it exactly as I grow but customer and
[ __ ] great kool-aid isn't it codeine
and a soda or whatever juice you want to
use I don't know but I know I got
friends that are addicts and stuff and
they've had a problem with that stuff to
they'll get addicted yeah money on
Michael yeah no I've had friends that we
know it's it's scary yes they get a lot
of discounts Robo tripping we caught it
our tussin and robitussin epiphan net ex
I never got in Fletch [ __ ] the craziest
thing I did my friend had a funeral
parlor we did the joint no formaldehyde
you wanna drive for any days it's [ __ ]
tremendous tremendous there's levels and
levels going on here that I'm not even
nice mix a spiritual person he's a
martial artist and he doesn't put you
Sam
and explain what both brothers is it
comes out of a group martial art system
called Kali or our niece or a screen
mattes basically stick fighting or comes
from the Philippines and so basically
it's a Filipino martial art based on
like with a lot of people see it because
it's stick fighting but in the old world
it was machete fighting and stuff but
it's become as somewhat of a sport in
America but the dog brothers are known
for
sort of kind of raising it up a little
bit kind of we do full contact fighting
we kind of do with those sticks yeah we
do like the you of cheeks take a look at
his hands I mean holding up to those
little cameras yeah we got them he's got
two knuckles yeah Oh God but um it's
basically like the UFC except we use
sticks and then we we wear a light
fencing mask like the old kind where you
can kind of press it looks like a screen
door and we use very light hockey gloves
or street hockey gloves or goalie gloves
from stalker can they hit you in the
head yeah the point is to either knock
them out submit them or whatever but
it's it has if you watch it and you
don't know about it it seems pretty
rough because it is but the idea is that
we're trying to push each other it's
like a tribal mentality we're trying to
push each other to be better to use like
foam sticks during the practice or
something yeah we do everyday practice
you would might use a foam stick or what
we call no wind sparring where you don't
make the stick move so fast and there's
lots of drills and stuff to practice
because they used to practice with
machetes out in the field maybe put the
cover on and practice so holy [ __ ] yeah
it was like it's kind of like like it's
kind of something an art that like a
farm worker might use in the Philippines
because they settled a lot of their
scores and family disputes with machetes
not much really weird that I didn't know
about this you know I'm like everybody
else in America you think that kung fu
China and all that stuff but there's a
whole system in Hawaii and there's a
whole system in the Philippines it's
very interesting because this like forms
a tempo in Hawaii that their roots come
from the Philippines and they mix it and
then we were discussing that like the
tempo I was studying the guy wanted you
to learn it with a knife first the move
then a stick then your fist or the efest
the knife long distance short distance
you did the exact same move only one
with a knife one with a stick so this is
all like ancient filled lake Philippines
created like what's that Kajukenbo
Kajukenbo was made by I think Hawaiian
yeah to fight the Americans when the
soldiers would come down and bully amid
bars
I devised this system like karate judo
yeah I think there's a the whole name is
split up of an acronym but I don't know
the full thing because I friend of Mines
really high up in Kajukenbo but they
were basically some bruiser guys and
they basically had a think tank and I
took the best from all their styles and
came up with this sort of ass-kicking
kung fu karate of Hawaii called
Kajukenbo know when I was younger did
Taekwondo and leave my master I guess
had a long thin stick mm-hmm is that
something like part of your thing or is
it just a short stick that you brought
along just a thin sticks I think of just
for like being a jerk and kind of
slapping your legs and like changing
your stance I mean we do because
supposedly thinner sticks are more like
a blade or something but really what we
use now as a stick it used to be for
training but we use a stick that'll
knock you out like you want a heavy
piece of rattan and we are trying to
knock each other out we go for about
three minutes we we were the dog
brothers were one of the first sort of
other groups besides Brazilian Jiu Jitsu
to incorporate Brazilian Jiu Jitsu or
grappling they were doing it they
incorporated with the Machado's into
their stick fighting system before the
UFC even came out so I think around 1988
I believe so they were training in the
garage with the Machado's and the gracie
steel so it's pretty interesting
cuz it's so violent it's so violent and
leaves even with an elbow I can't
imagine
get hit in the head with a [ __ ] stick
yeah that's a party
wait you're trying to knock each other
out but you have a helmet on yes so
you're gonna hit someone hard enough on
the head to deliver a concussive blow
that's gonna knock someone down yes but
not in class not in class we have like
twice a year we have what's called the
gathering of the pack where we come out
in different schools can come and we we
fight for three minutes it's like a
fight day but it has like I said
elements of a tribe like it would be
like kind of preparing for up I mean
it's kind of like burning man or like
preparing for a battle you see like
tribes getting ready and getting worked
up but it really is about bettering
ourselves it's not about beating people
down sometimes in like not the UFC so
much but like lower in cage fights it's
this kind of attitude of like destroy
them or beat them down or I beat you man
and the sportsmanship or the the sort of
tribal aspects aren't there so it's very
I've never been I've been in martial
arts my whole life I've been to
tournaments things like that but I've
never been to anything like this because
it's we're so far into the adrenal state
meaning like it's it's real like you
think you're gonna die and you're like I
shouldn't walk out on this mat but you
do and if you do and your duck went by
the time you get done you feel closer to
that person even though they're trying
to knock your block off that you're like
you kind of understand the other person
it's it's a very strange thing all the
martial arts give you a type of
spiritual essence
away they say that in Brazil they
jiu-jitsu II deal they played you Jitsu
with the lights off or blindfold it just
by feeling and you know I'm gonna lie
under the moon whatever the [ __ ] you
know and when you're doing forms
sometimes you're going to a different
straight state your breathing also
happens with yoga you know sometimes you
go to yoga just your breathing takes you
to that different you know they say it
opens up your chakras as they say you
know absolutely gets in the Alpha states
in the Alpha States so there's a
runner's high correct them and they
speak about a runner's high so I think
one that's why working on any levels
also it's always so great for you you
know at any level just breathing with
the oxygen going to all your you know
whether it's ticks psychics for Jesus
walking in and out birding whatever [ __ ]
you enter it always I remember living in
New York and New York you have to
[ __ ] walk and after why you start to
hate it but it's quicker you don't have
five hours for cab you don't have this
you just walk it try to a while you get
a Walkman whatever the [ __ ] an iPod you
know and I was walking around New York
there was a Walkman and then after a
while you decided whom this walk would
be a little better if I smoked the
[ __ ] number and all of a sudden you
listen to the almonds live and after
sweet Melissa tell me you don't go into
a [ __ ] heavenly [ __ ] state that you
have to somebody a car has to almost cut
you off for you to go what the [ __ ] is
this
that is the patois vol that [ __ ] you
know so I understand where he's coming
from I I understand that once somebody's
trying to hit you in the head
and with shaking hands it does let you
know about the other person so you see a
different side of that person
you know oh I know and I didn't try like
I get it so it was always very uh like
spear like not I don't not spiritual
boys very when I would go that they say
like this isn't to go fight this it was
always Brighton nice it's just the is it
like this is more violent ones I've ever
heard of any martial arts for you
growing up in age time did you grow up
in each town I grew up north of Houston
and a town con humble now I never really
did anything I played baseball and
soccer and you know we're really against
h's in Houston and humble we don't
pronounce them so oh the silent age oh
you so humble is how far from Houston oh
it's uh 15 miles north its I did comedy
there in humbled and um boy it's a
[ __ ] up place right there's no comedy
club there's no comedy club it's a bar
okay there was one bar and we did it
with this kid that was [ __ ] crazy and
the way you did comedy in front of the
door
basically people walked in you had a
move out of the way you understand me
only in Texas was this a paid gig yeah
yeah 50 bucks it was like once a month
they did it was on huh it was a [ __ ]
Horror Show
listen in music you do horror shows in
the beginning and in common you do
[ __ ] horror shows in the beginning
that's just part of it yeah sure and
this was one of those amen
you're busy tonight and you're out of
town you know I don't live in Houston
I'm in Houston when I'm in Houston
chillin anybody who comes to me with a
50 let's go
you know what the [ __ ] do I care might
go do these and I learned I went to all
those places
Pasadena Beaumont I used to love [ __ ]
boom I'll beat him Beaumont in three
days oh my god [ __ ] tremendous it's a
little broad I'm telling it right then
the Pappa those all that that whole area
was my [ __ ] little drug Kingdom there
right there there was a lot of drugs in
Houston actually yeah oh my god
specially in high school and stuff
really yeah like X was big and right he
was big when I first time I went to
stone was 1998 but the first time I had
ever learned about Houston was Monday
Night Football
when I wrote Campbell would play and me
and my boys would get on the phone and
go wait a second
[ __ ] the Pittsburgh Steelers do you see
what these crazy [ __ ] with
cowboy had to do it in Houston and next
thing you know we became a real Campbell
fans and I would always go I want to go
eat and then I became a Houston rocket
fan when they had Moses Malone that's
how deep I go back in if they used them
when they had Moses [ __ ] him alone and
then the 8th grade me and Chuck in me
Breen was called in to this [ __ ] show
and why do Donald took a bus from Jersey
to [ __ ] Piscataway and it would take
into New York City you had a switch
buses we told our moms you're going like
to the church Church we went to our
Moses that's when he used to be real
that this guy scored 31 points and had
19 rebounds there's like a bad night
well that's well he was a savage before
then Hakeem came and then then I became
in love with him again but that's but
then I went down to the Duke economy and
I was done 1998 the first time I walked
in there with Bobby slain that the last
stop on was great I was done guys I was
done this was the Kennison thing I just
read the book two weeks ago I read my
brother Sam I read it over again and
those first two chapters is just about
Houston and they were walking to go hang
outside a Mexican restaurant was ZZ Top
used to he that I get tears of my
[ __ ] eyes who walks to hang out of
the restaurant was easy top you staying
at some Mexican enjoy and I've seen
Billy Gibbons in town I had a yeah not
not to Chuy's but there's another like
tamale change oh no he likes some
Berryhill it the one on Sunset right by
the outcome Todd welcome sure the food
is horrible but the hell cane is
tremendous you know I'm saying
they [ __ ] I seen I seen Quentin
Tarantino get [ __ ] call he was
crawling out of that one night like they
knocked him on his little feet was
dragging on the floor they just threw
him in a car and [ __ ] back when I was
snorting blow and beat Lindsay Lohan
that was the game who could beat Lindsay
Lohan I used to see you there at 4:00 in
the afternoon
got lucky you got me Mike there
[ __ ] compadre that's why I saw Billy
Gibbons was not a Chuy's hat but a
Berryhill hat Mary Hill was another
tamale place in Houston that has a
really good lemonade Oh like some type
of Lima hey there's something Chuy's has
the margaritas they have the Elvis
chicken on Wednesday and on Mondays they
got sour cream chicken [ __ ]
enchiladas who the [ __ ] do you think
you're dealing with and then we in
Austin Austin and usually we're moving
in yeah we don't [ __ ] around here
well no choices in Austin and in Houston
right yeah yeah they have them both of
them that's more of a papacito's man and
I'm a Poppa see those men myself and in
Austin - that's a whole family that got
Pappas restaurant dog those that like
Cajun place casinos there's an Italian
one too right yeah zip pop Asifa are you
related to those Papa Doc you know
there's all kinds of crazy Papa's in
Patton in Houston well we would fries
Coney Island that was that was a pepper
doesn't attack this but they said what's
the Greek chain down in Houston
he owns one on West ray there's one
called the great Greek yeah and yeah the
great Greek and it's the same venture
what the [ __ ] is there because the kid
got into comedy and he would go to his
father's restaurant his father had three
great Greek restaurants that's why I
used to get the cheese omelet with the
steak fries but at the main one there
was this old man that had no patience
for nobody in Houston Texas he had like
the patience of a New Yorker and people
come in and give you a menu and I
remember one day was sitting and he
liked me because you should start
talking about politics and I would let
him roll when people start talking about
politics and they're knowledgeable but
they're at that dementia stage just let
him roll don't argue with him you know
he was talking about the Mormons
they own coca-cola and they [ __ ] well
you're trying to buy Houston but the guy
that shot the gun in Houston at the [ __ ]
I mean it was crazy this is deep but one
day he's sitting in some lady's like I
don't know I know they get the eggs we
got videos yes no yes no yes no make up
your [ __ ] mind I swear to God
and after that I wouldn't every [ __ ]
time I was in you I forget the [ __ ]
kid's name but Houston just had this
weird I bet it ends in an S yeah there's
never any purpose and they stab the
cheese the topless Costas good Sarkis
that was my friends yeah now I used to
run with grease in New York Helen ever
Metis Healthy Homes related I wrote
stuff on 42nd Street man so next time
you're in New York and yeah I'm 42nd
Street it's around the corner that's so
good
you never know what the [ __ ] people you
might be no good this friend of mine
I've just to go back to Billy Gibbons he
wrote for Guitar Player magazine you got
to interview him and he went to go
interview him he goes you want to get
something like Mexican food first and
you got to go to some Mexican food place
with Billy Gibbons which is like you
know like going to you know I don't know
going to Israel with Jesus or something
but then they ended up you want to go to
you want to continue this interview at a
titty bar and he's like ok so he goes to
that's titty bar with Billy Gibbons and
he's sitting there and he's so nervous
you know just like you would be hanging
with Paul McCartney or something and
like Billy Gibbons reaches over and goes
what kind of did is you like and the guy
didn't have any answer he was like he
could have said anything but he just
like froze up just Billy Gibbons but
well what do you what do you do and
Billy Gibbons asked you a [ __ ]
questions I'm not sure who he is
see this is what I'm talking about you
may have to run around who is the stick
let's start hitting right
we got you get into music in Houston not
real I got into music in Austin more so
and I did a lot of theater and many of
these punk rock plays and then when you
go to Austin for college they kind of
give you a guitar as you cross into the
city limits so you pick it up and you
learn rock and roll but it's too hard
then you learn the country's a hell of a
lot easier and it's the stuff I was
listening to my parents were listening
to all growin out so it's easier stuff
to play and easier to accompany yourself
so you just kind of move into that I
guess punk rock which is the same as
country it's just the same stuff but
pretty much yeah come on
well little I was metal and then I kind
of like what kind of metal like iron
made in a Judas Priest Oman yeah that
was like my jam when I was like a fifth
or sixth grade and then it moved into
like rat child the first two hours of 20
Deana well I came in and around with
like number of the beast okay and then a
electric guy screaming for vengeance
screaming for the home then I kind of
went backwards and then got into like
green man Olinsky and all that how good
is that [ __ ] it's still great how green
is though Judas Priest live do you like
that time I like some Iron Maiden but
every now but yeah I like what's on the
radio but I never went too deep into it
Jesus priest I think was my my band for
that stuff but then I immediately got
into that and I couldn't play it that
was another problem so then it kind of
got into like REM and u2 and the Smiths
and bad stuff it was amazing I didn't
know what the [ __ ] Judas Priest was I
had no idea
I like Black Sabbath yeah you know I
grew up you know 15 minutes from Madison
Square Garden so it was 15 bucks and on
yeah seven dollars you sat in those
bleeds and you ran down I want to see
yes every year you know I want to see
all these bands that's something yeah
yes was great back then I went to see
yes only times that towards the end we
started moving backwards like it was
just a horror show and these were the
days with the economy is something was
different because I mean yes came to
town they did four nights at the garden
three nights at the Nassau Coliseum two
nights in Asbury Park which is basically
you know ten nights in the same area
really so that means it was booming yeah
yeah so I remember the first time I even
heard you I ain't never even know any of
this songs I was in a detention type
class we have to sit there from 3:00 to
4:00 so take those you never hear this
only standees yeah and I was like oh
Jesus Christ really you know I brought
it home and it [ __ ] killed me
it just killed me and I was like where
the [ __ ] are these guys from he goes
Saturday night that play at the
Palladium going to see some of it the
Palladium was like going to Wembley
it's like going to London we [ __ ]
theater and I go how much of the tickets
act of all 50 and I had nobody to go
with
like everybody chickened out on me and I
had all but he walked oh like this music
store yeah things from England it was
gone northern New Jersey and they would
say you like every album but the
Australian version imports and imports
yeah it's still there this store is
still faster I'm the only idiot that
went and bought and it was a coldest
night and had to take a bus from
Boulevard East to the city and walk to
the Palladium and take a train and when
I got there it was just it was if he
came out with a [ __ ] whip and that's
the first time I realized he was gay but
I wasn't gonna say nothing I didn't get
me [ __ ] fetus Burien on the secret I
didn't give a [ __ ] he came out with a
whip and then they came out with
motorcycles took at the end and he came
out with a motorcycle on a [ __ ] whip
and people going nuts and I'm like look
at this savagery and I had no drugs
maybe smoke the joint by myself and I
remember I walked home like I was so
blown apart by Judas Priest because it
was a small place yeah
and that was November 29th 1979 I was a
sophomore in high school
and then they came back that June when
they did five nights at the Palladium
and I went all five nights for British
steel I was going to kill myself like my
life feels a great decent great [ __ ] you
know I was very fortunate you know I got
to see all those bands for 15 bucks
there about 50 well fifth okay let's
pretend you bought a ticket to go see
the Knicks on Tuesday night with dad on
the way I you look dad I have the
tickets disabled oh yeah son [ __ ] you
you cut those things they gonna first of
all they're gonna take a ticket and
basically rip it in half and give it to
you no that's your momentum is you know
say it row 15 aisle 6 seat number 4 you
do is I'd say it's a good tequila takes
a red ticket to the garden you don't
give a [ __ ] you come back the next week
with that rip stub and you put a fin
Stiller ruin that [ __ ] and the
old man and now I'm showing up with 10
deep so he's counting 10 [ __ ]
thinking this is 50 yards this is 50
bucks already I don't give a [ __ ] he
would you just stub your way and that's
called stubbing your way in you went
upstairs and you mind your business if
there were seats down below you walk
down there like a gentleman uh-huh but
it was not you didn't sit nobody's
seating cause no [ __ ] stairs and we
used together I want to see Michael
Jackson on a [ __ ] stud I used to
start I want to see the sixes against
the New York Knicks Christmas Day with a
[ __ ] stub how old-school am i sorry
about their areas why not it could be
better to see it now they scan
everything
no no no digital age nah they're dying
now visit action I want the seat turn on
Patti I went to see some great music
growing up
what's the first concert yeah what you
go see Billy Idol damn that aster world
how about you my brother the first
concert I saw was casing the sunshine
that the Easton livestock show and rodeo
can you believe that
how about you Lisa I have a stupid one
well we can't can't be worse than Casey
in the sunshine [ __ ] I think it might be
my dad got tickets from working he took
like my mom my brother and everyone
thought Janet Jackson at the fleet
center but like what do you guys think
because I'm I like music but it's not a
huge part of my life whenever I can end
up going to a concert or even like a
musical it it's not always like the best
audio-wise like it's not even sometimes
it isn't a great experience like what do
you guys think do you enjoy that more do
you enjoy listen to an album like that
like because sometimes you can't even
hear what they're saying
like do you enjoy the music more as a
different ER I mean if a if a performers
a good live performer yeah I prefer that
I mean the Grateful Dead sounds like
[ __ ] their studio records but I've been
to you know a few Grateful Dead shows
and it's it's a completely different
thing I mean it's like I don't know why
all these hippies are dancing like we're
dreadlocked white people but once you
get there you can't help but do it too
it's just it's there you know it's good
I love the live performance guys I love
the live performance and you know what
guess what I'm the type of guy even as a
young man I knew something [ __ ] up was
gonna happen let's just recover from
there and let's rock it from that point
mm-hmm I want to see Aerosmith as a
young man and they were possibly the
worst live concert I'll ever dantas
really whether they were high the sound
was bad the guy couldn't [ __ ] sing
you know I saw him in 77 they would run
two or three years after rocks they were
[ __ ] done and then they all broke up
in there and I went to see tonight I got
suckered again I want to see a Joe Perry
project open up for heart at the Radio
City musical all God talk about bad
and then I got suckered again I want to
see Aerosmith at the soap factory which
is possibly the federal it's that small
as the fan [ __ ] Aerosmith at the
federal which with the singer and there
were three two people left because the
one guy left with Ted Nugent's guy Scott
st. Holmes and they went in formed the
band nobody remembers that [ __ ]
that's what Scott same ohms went that's
why he didn't fly after stranglehold
waiting happened at Ted Nugent he
stopped singing that was [ __ ]
what's-his-name and then he left with
him and somebody else left and that was
the end of Harry Smith and I remember
that was he came out he threw a joint at
somebody and somebody grabbed them and
punched them and he had to run off the
stage of the soul factors that was it
then they came back with this walk this
way and everybody was happy and jumping
up and down and they're back on iTunes
and yeah lightning strikes wasn't that
an Aerosmith there that was worse video
oh yeah brutal
yeah but they really came back when they
really came when Run DMC yeah you walk
this way Jesus Christ oh I'm kind of
interested and it's a little bit
off-topic but for fans of podcasts we
kind of like have figured out like the
comedy business like you start open mic
then you like give a host a show you'll
be a future headliner like how does that
process work for people in bands like
cuz it's there's comedy clubs and
there's gonna be a new comic there I
don't know do you towards just bars like
what's that like well we've been doing
this just as kind of friends getting
together and I guess we're getting
people are coming out so we've kind of
plateau in the level that we're
comfortable out we're not taking the
show on the road mainly I mean I work as
an actor mainly I've been working on a
television show for the last 7 years so
we haven't been able to tour and I don't
want to be one of those actors that has
a [ __ ] band is I don't want to see
Kevin Bacon's ban or Russell Crowe's ban
or anything like that I I'm sure they're
great I just I'm not gonna care Kevin
Costner's man can you imagine going to
sit through that Dennis Quaid as a band
Dennis Quaid [ __ ] Billy Bob Thornton
yamo does he have a band don't but
[ __ ] playing drums of the Beach Boys
right now John Stamos's okay
it's a pass but it was the best actor
musician actor first did not first it
would be about Steve Martin yeah yeah
but that's he was that was part of his
comedy act before he became a big movie
star but now he's a Grammy winning
bluegrass yeah and he can really play
that banjo who would be the best though
I think probably Billy Bob right I don't
know I heard his stuff it bothered me
hey piss me off with Jones does the
[ __ ] guy from Baywatch yeah
Hasselhoff he's big in Germany
everything awesome he's knocking playing
the drums he's doing solos he's like
John Bonham my friend said that uh hate
crimes and David Hasselhoff are
connected because in Germany when they
started having hate crimes it was when
David Hasselhoff was coming up so I
don't know connection [ __ ] birthday
with house while he's at home right now
counting 20s wish I had his hair he's
counting [ __ ] 20s from now til the
end of time so you guys play every
weekend I mean the process that Lee was
looking for is it's truly sometimes
there's uh when you start in Michigan
you'll go to a comedy club one night and
there's a guy up there destroying the
plants destroying the [ __ ] place and
you're like Jesus Christ who is this guy
you know I've been don't count in 15
years I come in at Mary and he gets off
the stage and you go by thing you're
like a man Joey Diaz living in LA that
was tremendous man how come I never
heard you guys like have four kids uh my
wife's a teacher my family's yeah I
[ __ ] hate this son and you know I
have you ever considered going away and
he's like for what I have four kids I'm
content with who I am and you leave
there blown away but then after you
think about it you know that guy's
happier than I am yeah you know he knows
what the [ __ ] he is he's fine with it
he knows this is what it is it's a
weekend gig
and there's a guy particularly in
Chicago Mike to me that's a guy that's a
killer so much is a killer that one
night Kennison was coming into a club
and they told us in this Sam walks in
you have to get off and Sam walked there
he kept seeing Sam and he kept saying
when is he gonna give me the light and
when he got off Sam off for the me
because I've never seen nothing like
that a guy killed clean he kills he
destroys clean I mean [ __ ] destroys
like just boom like remains go off now
he works for a radio station he's old
I'm 51 he's got to be 50 for some you
know but he was comfortable and that's
always great to see that's the other
side of music you know I know that you
do your martial arts you do you do it
you know you do 19 [ __ ] things don't
you yeah you [ __ ] consult on a show
you're in the Navy you [ __ ] search
people at the airport this guy's a
savage he goes to jujitsu you know I
mean so sometimes people know where they
that's it and that's a great place to be
before podcasting I swear to god guys
listen I loved when I came around I just
wanted to stand-up comedy but then your
manage this is a man there's these
movies you want to dismiss and you know
these audition is this [ __ ] and after a
while I can't even what acting you see
it for what it is you know what you want
to do and sometimes people call you up
in like I'm not going downtown at 4:50
in the afternoon
yeah I'm comfortable that's not gonna
change my life I already got level two
insurance I'm good to go
July you know I mean
that's how you know you there's people
that you see you ever go out and you see
people that are open nosed like their
[ __ ] noses are open and they're like
[ __ ] foaming from the mouth
I smell be a [ __ ] star edits and you
see them on Facebook and yet I do this
[ __ ] you and after a while you're like
really all this at the end for what for
what you going all-out killing yourself
for what and I'm the [ __ ] moving here
and wanted to do everything people call
you and you yes them and now you're
there at 2:00 in the morning sitting on
the [ __ ] back of a car with tomato
juice on your [ __ ] face waiting for
the bar to close because that's the only
really to shoot the scene and then you
get to the [ __ ] there premiere
they're gonna have is that Club 1716 on
Sunset where you gotta bring your own
[ __ ] popcorn it's not even a real
Hollywood premiere and they got some
post up with pictures from so it's
[ __ ] embarrassing like you feel a
stay at home it's not how many Puerto
Ricans you shoot it's who you [ __ ]
shoot we get the size of leak look at
the size of your eyeballs they're done
yeah that's a nice end that's I love
that I love that concept no it's I know
this is a hobby like this is like just
two guys now how many people are sorry
I'm at full strength there's 12 of us oh
yeah
it's a collective so guys take the
envelope at the end of the night chop it
up twelve ways no boys first time do you
really have much time we hold up to my
hair good thing everybody gets a few
hundred bucks at Christmas time yeah and
what we can say about the ban is for the
most part no one puts any money out to
be in the band if you've ever been in
bands before it's you're always putting
money out yeah now how the idea come
about like this it just guys get
together me and a couple buddies we used
to meet at this Cajun restaurant they
call it a Cajun restaurant the food
wasn't that good but they had an upright
piano in the back and they give us a
beer special then we can smoke
cigarettes and bring our instruments
around the piano
a piano player and guitar players a
banjo guy plays a washtub bass in our
band he's made of bass with one string
on a washtub and so we just started
playing at that place and we kind of
kept them alive for a few more months
and then they closed down so we found
another place so we just kind of moved
around with the basis being we were
looking for places that kind of had
southern food because we're all southern
boys and we were just look at places in
LA where we could meet once a week and
drink and play and have our friends come
out and we started getting better and
yeah so we started playing some clubs
and venues and now the federal likes us
and we loved in there it's a they have a
great sound system they're really nice
to us they're fetus they pay us and we
get to take part of the door and we get
a few drinks yeah Thursday house band I
guess you could say it villains tavern
for like three years
yeah it's this downtown place it's the
bars thought now I don't want to speak
out against them because they started
being nice to us again but whose I'm
tired of then waiting 25 minutes to get
it drinks is there mass with some
hipsters blueberries that's what I yeah
yeah serve in a mason jar is just like
it's amazing what you go through and
it's amazing where you start saying no -
and yes - yeah you know it's amazing
what you start saying yes - no - because
you know you could tolerate after a
while yeah you know you know you know
it's an it's the same with calm you know
I could never imagine being in a band
where you know Guns and Roses five guys
they all have to agree on the same thing
every [ __ ] day of the week that's
never gonna happen and that's why you
know that's never gonna [ __ ] happen
but you guys people come and go no it's
the same tall guys it's been pretty much
the same we just haven't fired anybody
if somebody wants to go they can yeah
but yeah if someone can't make it we
still plays they've got enough people we
have a backup we can't do it without our
drummer it's hard to do without the
drummer how many nights a week do you
rehearse we don't rehearse donek gigs
our rehearsals yeah games that we play
for three hours each gig
like the p-funk of country music you
can't get a soft stage basically and you
guys ever go to Austin perform haven't
yet we have a couple invitations like I
said I've been working on a television
show and now that that shows over it was
called True Blood and now that show's
over I have all this time on my here's
the it's over yeah it's a few more
episodes left but I mean I'd certainly
like to jump into another television
show because how was it working on True
Blood it was great man it was a great
job I got some I mean it's really
popular I'm just learning I'm scared of
[ __ ] van I didn't care about it when
I started and I still vampires it's not
my favorite that's a fiction to read or
anything like that but I didn't play a
vampire I played a veteran with PTSD and
that's kind of how Nick and I got a
little bit closer because Nick's it was
in the Navy and he knows it's martial
arts and I don't know how to fight at
all and I came to him and I said ain't I
can you toughen me up at least made it
look like I know how to fight and he
would help me and yeah teach me how to
move a little bit better
nextly you've done it a variety of
martial arts what is it what did you
start first karate up at the front of
the subdivision you know where I grew up
they were giving away like Chinese stars
be signed up or like a rubber chucks or
something so I started there and it was
actually pretty cool because my
instructor was pretty open-minded he did
come foo and karate and Japanese Jiu
Jitsu so he's kind of like back then it
was kind of a mixed martial art so not
like we think of today but then this
Filipino guy came through and did a
couple of them did a demo at one of the
karate tournaments and they had a real
knife and they're trying to stab each
other with it and they would do these
demos with it and I just was blown away
cuz you grew up here this was in Houston
I do
around 1980 Wow Filipinos yeah I know
but they call the Mexicans but right
there just mingles yeah exactly but
Richard a big Vietnamese community in
Houston there's a huge Vietnamese yeah
yeah and so I was hooked or still doing
the karate but they would uh you know at
one night a week or something they do
Filipino stuff and I just loved it I
would drive all over Texas because there
wasn't the internet back then where you
get just YouTube everything I heard of a
guy in San Antonio's I Drive to San
Antonio's a guy in Austin I Drive to
Austin and I tried to pick it up then I
came to California and it was just
rampant
you said Chinese stars cuz I had a
couple is it yeah I never knew what did
I try to stick them on a tree and so
what is the practical application of a
Chinese star you throw it at your
adversary yeah like it would be like I'm
supposed to get poison and they're quiet
I think they're also gotcha Ricans or
shura cons or whatever you want didn't
work no it didn't those [ __ ] things
never stuck in the war I had a thousand
is a throme at everything the teddy bear
everybody was getting [ __ ] instead
nothing ever happens ended up in the
yard no like Oh God when they owe the
law and it's gonna be because they sell
them to you but then you have taken to a
hardware store they get [ __ ] on it
yes and the guy would look at you weird
you know you have a relationship with
the guy you wouldn't let why see here
for glue and paint and now [ __ ] it you
know it's it's it's really amazing how
martial arts if you joined in early you
you became this martial arts nerd
because I was and every time I and when
I dropped out
bad I'll say that for years was that
quit I quit in the February by March I
started smoking heavy I would just get
high but not when I was hanging out with
the karate kids and I was at the karate
kids we were looking like jeez you know
demonstrations we would go and Bulldog
other schools [ __ ] what's up [ __ ]
dojo bashing that was your bashing it
was just you know it was just a
different section and then you meet a
burger canyon [ __ ] fight it out those
sidekicks and the teachers are get the
guy was [ __ ] silly but it was that's
what it was you know nobody wants to
[ __ ] stab Rita have they found war
machine yet no but Dog the Bounty
Hunter's looking for him oh [ __ ]
yeah yeah I just read it on the internet
today you called him out and told him
you have 4 hours to surrender I read the
statement you know the guy was dressed
and they have him for seven charges I
did see that but I looked at the charts
and those charges were like Jack I read
it a different way if he took me in the
shower it's again so will that's
kidnapping that's kidnapping
okay sexual assault sexual assault if he
cut her hair I mean that's some [ __ ]
heavy-duty charges there I'm just
telling you from one honored experience
and from a personal experience of my own
that when you take somebody from one
dwelling and for the other it's
kidnapping okay what it just ain't cool
I was reading that and I was like I'll
know when you're reading I was like what
is he going where is he going through
right now because he's not like from in
his mind
I can't he's not gonna get away like
what did someone like that when you know
they're coming after you what is he
going through look at he's got a [ __ ]
grenade on his neck okay so let's say he
puts makeup on that because that's what
I thought of
oh yeah he's like he was yeah was him so
let's say somebody said that he's in
Canada yeah couldn't have been in Canada
already if he got in the car Friday in
Las Vegas one does he make it to capital
e Sunday night maybe Monday morning
gentlemen you have to come X
don't you think would you do they check
you going into Mexico now yeah yeah a
second yeah so let's say he left Vegas
at five in the [ __ ] morning where
would he go would he go [ __ ] south to
Mexico where the [ __ ] would he go he's
in a panic he's gonna panic he's gonna
panic he's got to stop and get money
clothes that's that's an hour and he's
got time like cops had already been
there he's got to get a lot of cash he's
probably got a if he knows enough to get
rid of his credit cards and because any
transaction can be traced yeah no catch
I don't know yeah once you go by know
where it is the phone gets stepped on
that goes under in a lake boom that's it
there's no communication yeah that phone
gets shut off then they pick up his car
god knows what I mean
I can't imagine being him right now and
feeling what he's feeling and the
remorse he's feeling mix that will ever
make some hack that way and the anger
and guys you know you see this anything
about well this guy had a history of
assault right yeah history is just
[ __ ] being a lunatic yeah yeah you
know and he's pretty juiced up from most
descriptions well then it just happened
like a week or two ago with the guy in
Boston who like be on his wife and then
trains his dog to bite his wife another
ex UFC guy yeah well there's been boxers
that have bit their opponents he's sure
no he made him quite a comeback you know
there were people mad because of John
Jones and cornea
I thought that was our example in boxing
four years yeah it happens in boxing
free is two guys hate each other they
cross a line I mean I read that that
Duran book how he insulted Sugar Ray's
wife that's how come he beat him he told
his wife was a [ __ ] thing so I'm [ __ ]
on the ass and [ __ ] already nearly
melted you know but it's just today I
was like what the [ __ ] is this cuz I
didn't know Dog the Bounty Hunter was on
I mean what is this guy thinking right
now I mean I've been in that situation
with people looking for you what the
[ __ ] you think yeah does he get made up
does he turn himself in he turns himself
in guys he's doing it was all violent so
they give him 18 he's gonna do 17 and 3
[ __ ] quarters and I here in Vegas they
don't [ __ ] around that's what I hear I
don't know how serious their I know they
give you time for weed and so for tying
a [ __ ] up and put them in the [ __ ]
shower and cutting the hair off that's
gotta be ten years right there that's
without the [ __ ] eighteen bones
broken it's just a horrible thing you
know what I don't even get out of the
dudes face did you read that yeah she
was with no yeah come on yeah well I
mean this is this is just all
speculation it's just stuff I'm reading
but yeah and he was a former reality
show contestant or something
it's just that it's just a bad energy to
be involved around for some people who
are highly violent I like that you know
you know who the [ __ ] knows what
happened will really happen when he got
there
you know but I praise from the church or
with him with you know he said me saying
only that my prayers are what you
[ __ ] I bought what do you don't doing
you the whole mom was waiting yeah well
yeah I'm doing with your [ __ ] red
shirt and your red eyeball with a big
stop sign your [ __ ] yeah yeah now we
wanted the hood we're big fans and music
man you know music is part of the thingy
the problem is YouTube cuz you [ __ ]
music off and [ __ ] so the podcast will
keep it so that's the problem I wish
people would just let us play their
music because it just makes sense you
know how would you bring a CD yeah yeah
we own it at least the first four tracks
that's us
you sell these - yeah give away alright
it's hard to sell music this is it that
says this is this industry when it's
amazing how it's changed yeah in 20 it's
amazing that when I got that way I would
go to that mall and get a coffee and I'd
walk into one by the Laugh Factory
yeah what's that more there what's the
name of that coffee sunset 5 so I said 5
what's that coffee place and that's been
there since Jesus left [ __ ] first
time I went in there ever Georgia the
jungle was in there I almost had a heart
attack
what's his name Brendan Fraser Brendan
Fraser my second dana I got here Monday
night Tuesday I was waiting online at
the Laugh Factory that dude three
minutes and we switch to go get coffees
in that place
the point being there was a record store
in that correctly I was there was a
Tower Records okay how big was that just
so people at home know how big was that
[ __ ] yeah I was huge but now I'm
Eva which is in Hollywood now not there
on the strip but that's an enormous
record store
that's yes for the music enthusiast you
walk into an amoeba
it's like a [ __ ] it's like walking
for your ambling yeah like walking into
Las Vegas if you're again me like when I
walk into on me by make sure I have like
a little credit card like the one that's
got three for the other if you can't do
that much damage because there's [ __ ]
you find like I saw an album I was
looking for this particular Cuban album
and I went on eBay and all that [ __ ]
they wanted a yardstick flight the
cheapest who had it was 90 bucks I'm
gonna told me but I had to see the
$15.99 BAM I bought three of them just
to go just in case if I ever lose again
they've got everything a [ __ ] owe me
man they got one in San Francisco yeah
[ __ ] places but it's amazing that
there were two big record chains and the
other one by Starbucks on the corner
there on the other side of the sunset
there was a tower I worried there was
something else on the other side that's
gone good god no not anymore
I don't even nothing not that's it so
well the point being is it and people
want to buy a music no more and now you
have to tour like [ __ ] savages yeah
to make you know and at the end even if
you saw eight thousand tickets they
still come to you you're in the [ __ ]
red by the way insurance hot dogs for
the staff oh you sang one song too many
that puts everybody on triple overtime
at $2,000 a [ __ ] night and next thing
you know you're like what do you tour in
the [ __ ] didn't pay your label that's
amazing when I don't know the the people
or the guy's name but when I lived on
Sunset 1440 God or Ralphie May and Ricky
cruise and all those guys down there
there was kid named Martin and he was
friends with the kid would come over he
looked familiar
there was the kid who his band opened up
for Rage Against the Machine on a big
tour
I know that guys must movie talk about
money and my friends like that guy can
barely pay rent because they sing like
for so long do something yeah and
everything goes to the record label to
pay the studio time he's dying and I was
shocked you're opening up a rage against
the [ __ ] machine and you [ __ ]
broke what you know what do things bad
all over that's Maya Lee why you looking
at me like a [ __ ] Matador what well
he was saying what's the like the train
of success for a band like for a comic
it's kind of changed like when we first
started playing music we were little it
was always like get a record deal if
they could just see you or you make your
demo and then you give it to someone and
then they make your record better yeah
that's like what people used to do so
we're not petty talking about that
yeah and then there was the if you sell
out like the club like you're in Jersey
and you just get five or you know 300
people to come every Friday night the
record company will find you that was
like one other sort of things now you
learn how to use the Pro Tools or
whatever you make your own record you
put it on and you can do that that's a
Avenue now it's amazing what a band
could do and two and a half years with
social media thing yeah with no nothing
but this would cost a bad time and
there's you know a lot of money but five
guys that know each other that was
serious about something and they each
had the same commitment you know to get
together you know once a week to
rehearse and after six months playing
whatever I don't know how the music
business works but what I'm trying to
say is social media could really because
you just blast them on Facebook and
Twitter but at the same time you give
them little pieces you twit yeah the
live performance is everything ties
together but it takes time people want
to do it for four months and they go
this doesn't work no you [ __ ] you
gotta keep doing it you got to do it the
same way every day and people one day
will pay attention and go why is this
[ __ ]
loke [ __ ] sweet mrs. [ __ ] goddamn
song every [ __ ] day and he clicks it
on when he's like I did this [ __ ] now
they listen to to you song but it takes
time and I think that the same way
Twitter worked for comics it would work
in the music industry for that but now a
musician you control everything
Joey are you big on Twitter are you yeah
yeah I really like it it's worked for me
were you reluctant when it first started
oh [ __ ] yeah like you don't want to give
your jokes away I mean you you write you
think of something funny you tweet it
does that go in the act
I've wondered how this works for comics
here it is
so you [ __ ] [ __ ] table
Robin Williams died on Monday how long
do you hear the first Robin Williams Joe
okay so tomorrow night you turn on CNN
and know what the [ __ ] TV show you
watching he says that jump or any other
topical joke topical joke is something
not about yourself but of the dailies
events uh-huh and it's a hysterical
sometimes you might see someone with six
o'clock news if you could work that
[ __ ] by 10:45 at the Comedy Store and
there's 200 people $1,100 watch the
[ __ ] six o'clock news they all watch
the same clip you already had the thing
you look like a [ __ ] hero how long
has that big gonna last two weeks it's a
throwaway bit that's all Twitter is it's
a throwaway bit I love these people that
go hey guess what la hootenanny at the
fennel tweet me right now the first five
people you give away five tickets that's
[ __ ] great but I didn't see no value
in that [ __ ] tweet give me a [ __ ]
song and give me a funny tweet hey you
Texas [ __ ] listen to this taxes
gonna the [ __ ] boom they hear whatever
little country a little bit whatever the
[ __ ] they hear warm with something else
you got them involved people on Twitter
want to be involved I've been on Twitter
at 3:00 in the morning
people in [ __ ] England there you are
you that in Sami you got nothing else to
do Twitter for me worked as a writing
tool for just something topical man
something that just happened that your
first reaction your first real [ __ ]
reaction because that's the only way
you're gonna get this to work if you
even but you got to push the envelope a
little bit and that's what it really
comes to we're very nice people in this
room but when we see something we see it
in our twist we don't repeat what we see
those aren't a real [ __ ] thoughts
sometimes you have to put those in
Twitter in 140 characters or less and it
works out Lee how does it not work that
I've had I've been banned from both of
them I have a picture of my nutsack with
it for the longest [ __ ] time when I
hit you in a message you got a picture
of your nutsack but that's a social
medias about if I could [ __ ] every day I
said if I was a plumber I'd be on
Twitter because it's 30% more business
for you I don't know exactly what the
secret be for music but you saw me
yourself you give away L a hootenanny
some of yourself some you give away you
put five songs on here and the eighties
they used to make ep's rap released an
EP a Ozzy Osbourne released an EP give
away that road and then some of the
other four songs yeah I don't know I
don't know yeah but there's got to be
some way a band listen to that 20 years
ago everybody went to Motley Crue be
still 34 to 35 years ago right yeah what
was the formula then you went to that
place you got a wig
you can watch tight pants flying out of
the city yeah yells [ __ ] yes the motley
crew like you like what the [ __ ] is this
these guys really did saw that so some
of the music is great the rest of the
[ __ ] singer you like what the [ __ ] am
i listed but what was the pattern then
it changes the same way it changes for a
comedian when I got here you you popped
up on a TV show and you wanna have the
road it people automatically came to see
I got my first TV show guess how many
people came to see nobody
but not MADtv that's like one of the
best comedy shows people put on there
from MADtv nobody came to see me then
they go you got to get a movie I got a
movie nobody came to [ __ ] see me it
changes what is the pattern now you know
what how would a a musician make food at
work for the more you've been a podcast
well you can't put music we're not as
clever as a comic so we're not going to
put little witnesses I mean yeah I don't
mix well I mean level these clap mix
club is clever next look Nick put
pictures you were the people in the head
with sticks and people love that [ __ ]
we do try to put as much content on our
facebook page as possible just let
people know we're still out there you
know occasionally put just something
because a lot of us are actors in the
band and so if they're on a TV show that
night we'll put a little clip about it
or something but it would put I think
there's an L a hootenanny Twitter
account right now I I never Twitter on
my Twitter for a little bit but I think
Twitter Facebook you might may not be
tweeting with other girls so it's like I
gotta became a boss on that I don't know
how to do the privacy and hide [ __ ] so
let me ask you something so you record
on True Blood I was in the cast you bad
[ __ ] yeah it was you biting
people the next no yeah yeah I was a vet
and I my character died last season but
in this last season there's ghosts and
everything tremendous yeah now you take
it up at that farm of that yeah my buddy
real ranch is that what you're talking
to me yeah because Mike Bunny Calabasas
yeah his girlfriend she's a comic book
ER and he runs the ranch
something he's told me a couple times I
want to come up I figured Jason
something I forget what the [ __ ] yeah
yeah his parents have oh yes the
caretaker
right right right and then in the second
season we had this big tree that they
made out of meat because this crazy
witch lady was taking over the town and
I think he had to sit out there with the
22 rifles and keep the keep the Coyotes
I think the meat are Dmitry yeah how
many episodes is your habit
I guess about 60 and are you happy it's
over I mean I like the paycheck don't
get me wrong it was nice and I'm hoping
to find another TV show but yeah but the
role fit me like a glove and the people
were very nice I know it sounds cliche
but we felt familiar but they hired me
the two stars Anna Paquin and Steve
Moyer number one and two on the call
sheet they got married in the second
season so they hired me to play their
wedding out in Malibu so yeah it's a
close-knit group of people your wife in
the show yeah we're pals yeah she comes
out to see us and yeah so I'm gonna miss
everybody everybody's gonna go their
separate ways but I made contacts that I
don't know for the rest of my life
fingers crossed I love the diversity
here I love that you know you play music
but you know you act but your outlet is
your music yeah which is [ __ ]
beautiful I mean I wish people knew that
that life exists that's just a dream
life it's a dream life it's a dream life
right now until the money dries up and
even I just never be able to do it just
now be able to have the opportunity to
go do what you really love on somebody
else's nickel you know why you're doing
something and on your other hand you
know
I like you that you're a bad
[ __ ] you're a great martial
artist yeah you know you're great Jitsu
guy who taught me a lot how to breathe
you [ __ ] taught me moves and [ __ ] you
know you're in the Hall of Fame
yeah he's just got inducted you were in
the Navy I made something the [ __ ]
Navy yeah that was a pretty trippy one
and you're out now no no I mean I'm a
public affairs officer I'm a reservist
my dad was a Navy pilot so I was always
groomed to be in the Navy be a pilot and
then my eyes went bad or something when
I was a little kid but do you wear
corrective lenses now I got lazy oh you
got nice yeah
about 10 years ago it still works but I
was always supposed to be in the Navy
and my dad was an airline pilot too so
planes were like we were all about
planes but I just kind of fell back into
the my parents were real supportive just
fell into the arts martial arts movie
making music and I just eventually went
on this Hollywood tour of the Navy that
the public affairs department the Navy
does and he was like I was like I always
thought I'd be in the Navy but I'm too
old and he goes well there's this
program that you know you have a lot of
media experience they kind of uh put you
in the Navy and so I went in ISM I got a
commission as an officer and public
affairs ever since and you still do
tourneys you teach it I mean right so we
could teach over vemma I do Monday
nights and our colleague program goes
Wednesday and Thursday but I just teach
Mondays and then I teach I have like my
backyard group I teach on Saturdays we
get to eat each other more and curse
more and stuff so that's kind of my out
in the park called picnic style
shoot the [ __ ] a little bit you know
swing some sticks tell lies just wing
some more sticks it's real laid-back I'm
not gonna lie to you guys man when I got
into comedy I had just got out of prison
and I was mad having that little girl I
was a roofer and I became an estimator
for the company and I was very content I
never never dreamt about being that way
I never even not even it never even
crossed my [ __ ] mind I would read
about egg bees and are you from here I
know you well no I don't know a little
bit yeah I would read about the Queen's
in the Comi store and Pasadena the Ice
House and I would like tears would come
to mind that I would never have that
happen every [ __ ] I'm sure you've
said this on your show before but I've
just met you but where did you first go
up where was your first set at The
Comedy Works in Denver
that was my first set were you living in
Denver and I was living in Boulder I was
like a scorned Bolin I got pinched with
drugs and [ __ ] and I came out you know I
was always like the guy in the corner on
the bus we're always talking [ __ ] and
then but that I'm not gonna lie the
people at home earlier you guys when I
got interest I always thought I would
have a day job and this would be Tuesday
here forever here Saturday if I was
lucky enough maybe somebody come to town
and shoot a movie if I could be an extra
I would be very happy and then this just
moves so [ __ ] quickly once I got into
this it was just one thing led to the
other and all some people like one you
gonna have a day job and one minute
you're in Seattle one minute you're in a
car to the Laugh Factory you next thing
back in the car you living on sunset in
a [ __ ] Toyota you know and taking
showers at Ralphie Mae's house and doing
spots at the store and going on the road
and it's just you end up here what a
beautiful thing same thing with like
movies and TV it's amazing I never ever
thought I would ever get a role I was
good enough I went to an NYPD blue
audition and a t-shirt with a whistle on
I kept going through Fox and somebody
popped out as I was walking it was Libby
Libby Jordan Libby Johnson and she goes
are you here for an audition
I guess I Libby Goldstein she works with
she did True Blood I don't know if
that's the one they're in an office like
with two other a guy and a chick or
something like that Junie Johnson yeah
he got office yes so I see her and she
goes in here for the audition yeah she
comes out boom I read it read it again
okay thank you
I'm living in a [ __ ] hotel on
Schrader is the hostel now blow up
stairs after the college so I have
rubber furniture in my room I have those
little [ __ ] towels with like
cigarette burns of them in [ __ ] and
awesome no ideas phone call I go down
that's my man just like you booked bass
ketball you've got three weeks on bass
ketball for fifty five hundred hours a
week guys no such a good call
yeah I've never heard anything like that
my life yeah and I kept saying 5500 what
what the [ __ ] are you saying he's like
they gotta give you fifty five hundred a
week plus a per diem [ __ ] for three
weeks per diem hey guy he's like I got
you a medium trailer what are you saying
what [ __ ] trail are you talking about
what what and he goes but you got a
joint sag it's 1250 and you didn't have
it I was - eighteen thousand would he
lend it to you did you ask things like I
asked my nan they wouldn't yeah the last
day the production company with
wrote the check and said we'll take it
out you asked me no questions I'll tell
you no less so sad was on the yard 1250
yesterday I'm walking the baby in the
cart and I see a guy from the
neighborhood
he's walking there's a little chihuahua
nice little Spanish guy we start talking
I wish I'd some watch them with the dog
for like three years and we're talking
and he goes he goes can I ask you a
personal question I know why he goes how
much they cost you join sag or 1250 he
just those [ __ ] thieves they want
$3,000 gone up yeah $3,000 to become a
[ __ ] and for what then then you have
to pay for your health insurance now
it's still reasonable no it's reasonable
but it used to be free seven years ago
oh my god it stings the [ __ ] chains
Elysees I look at you reason the thing
with wheezing a [ __ ] flat toe he's
doing he's burning 800 calories a day
he hasn't [ __ ] gone to the bathroom
in a week when I was a sophomore I
spotted another bathroom for a [ __ ]
like three days we were on a bus from
East Orange New Jersey enough Barry with
a bunch of chili as I dropped the fart
it was the worst thing I ever smelled my
life girls are crying it was [ __ ]
classic they kept blaming on the bus
driver [ __ ] Lee you gotta go you
gotta go to extreme measures [ __ ] you
gotta go CVS is like a pharmacist pull
them aside go listen I believe the
hummus for [ __ ] 18 is some coffee
drink a bottle of whiskey tonight you'll
be fine to me yeah with cigarettes you
sit there for a little while
wiggle the muffler push but don't push
too hard that's what killed Elvis yeah
just push maintains that relax you know
what you only cereal you don't do not
you don't need lettuce why don't you
kill me that's why green I mean I just
went 50
so that went they stuck the [ __ ]
camera my [ __ ]
they took pictures I got the pictures of
the house you gotta see the tubes see
that's [ __ ] hummus nothing and they
gave me the whole picture
from let's say that's the [ __ ]
they show the camera go right up tight
tight little [ __ ] muffler it even had
that [ __ ] twist to it at the end and
then they pop it open I don't know how
it's like they see my [ __ ] then
they're in my ass then they don't show
the fingers none they're [ __ ] smart
those [ __ ] they know I got you
attorneys they [ __ ] and then they
show the whole thing leave the
intestines the whole thing I had four
little [ __ ] marks you don't want that
and the guy said you look [ __ ]
tremendous keep doing what you're doing
I try to fight you don't let it sleep I
eat lettuce when you have two pieces of
counting how big was your self what else
is it it was just a Caesar salad one
while you were what kind of what kind of
meat chicken chicken what kind of
chicken sharp one right child bro
they probably got that frozen [ __ ] from
rouse you know I make chemicals that god
bless you though as long as you don't
get help don't become one of those
[ __ ] in the taps on Twitter if you're
an out be keep going at this point you
did seven years on the show you deserve
it
so I prefer can we give some [ __ ]
shoutouts here doing people to see no
I'm gonna play the CD you guys gonna
play some music don't want to know with
Nick right there rotschild I love you
Bergy we love the [ __ ] you know what
I'm talk
surveillance 702 always water boxer get
it together [ __ ]
Amanda self dado Jason cigars and Tonio
Martinez Gambas Eenie
and Jake Ryan I love you [ __ ]
thank you for being part of the Church
of what's happening now you know where I
was
shouts out you gotta make people daily
your [ __ ] mama fight over there
probably there's no problem you're
sitting there like you know back in huh
he's not gonna be able to get back he's
gonna be fine
the over they trying to text the girl
yeah like a Matt you're not charged 800
hours maybe I get your 10% on speaker
10% off audit calm [ __ ] it today I got a
boxer I got two boxes of our strong ball
a nice after my surgery very simple to
me I got a little thing a [ __ ]
whatever I popped it today before he
gave Machado's [ __ ] class work a
storm fruit export and I [ __ ] lasted
me and the kid did some life [ __ ]
inspiring I did the class and we did
more [ __ ] inspiring than this Brown boat
took me and [ __ ] me up
he wasn't nice like you he [ __ ] me I'm
not my he [ __ ] did some [ __ ] no
really that was high-level yeah we get
beat up you like impressed with the
beatin like that damn he [ __ ] beat me
up good like it takes a man sometimes
that's why you learn you're absolutely
right sometimes that's why it's tough
for a lot of people to go to jiu-jitsu
oh yeah a lot of people can't take that
that me I don't give a [ __ ] trust though
- yes armor on your neck if he decides
to keep it on he's a lot better than you
yeah that's rough and sometimes your
arms get stuck and [ __ ] you don't you
know I always trying to position myself
as he's going and block one and keep
that I keep that top hand right [ __ ]
there anyway you won't need that [ __ ]
top hat if you go in on it calm you
understand but you will never [ __ ]
fat with the head protein I'm telling
you right now the chocolate the acai
vanilla I [ __ ] love it superb you
know I truly believe in these people
like I said this is not just a
supplement
this is optimization as they [ __ ] say
it's a different level for your body for
your mind for your souls are hitting
somebody with the [ __ ] sticks on that
number two I wanna give a shout out to
my main people naturebox.com/tyler [ __ ]
is always throwing heat in my heart you
understand me always
I gotta start doubling up on you people
the [ __ ] snacks are delicious I'm
getting slimmer and you know why because
their nutritionists approve and I don't
like a [ __ ] Savage I open up the bag
they're zip bags so when you get
naturebox comude on't have to eat the
whole [ __ ] thing like a new bike
chips you gotta [ __ ] open up the
chips eat them but then you feel guilty
because you gotta put that butterfly
thing in your Lord Roach is gonna get
into in the middle of the night and it's
gonna [ __ ] up your chips they say we
know what [ __ ] that I'm gonna eat all
the chips cuz I'm gonna get mine yeah
I'm saying [ __ ] it not with naturebox
naturebox comes with a resealable seal
trust monitoring these snacks are
[ __ ] world-class I wouldn't be
sitting here [ __ ] dropping knowledge
I knew [ __ ] nutritionist approved
the healthy most importantly they
[ __ ] taste good look at these people
people doing blow what kind of offices
you got really go to nature's box calm
go to the box press enter Joey Joey Joey
why got fifty percent off your first
daughter Tom Lee you think you're pissin
off me what the [ __ ] you said Tommy it's
your 50% that's your fault
tell names buck we send you so what do
you do you own the box and price Joey
Joey naturebox.com/tyler box first door
also my brothers up there David and
Peter my main dogs up at Nelda life calm
they have to [ __ ] vapor pens they got
people out there beeping like [ __ ]
savages I'm like it's Jim at middle of
the night they got paper pens they got
over there
they got t-shirts on the website goomy's
gummies I don't think they can send the
[ __ ] dummies against the law you
can't come you gonna be like Cheech
you're on you're [ __ ] on I'm not
gonna go to jail for you for saying
gummies that's supposed to sell well if
you're in the area [ __ ] vapor pants
only the best way propelling the market
go to nail delight calm get 20% off what
are you pressing up box Lee you just
mentioned Joey Diaz Joey Diaz back and I
want to re welcome some of the best [ __ ]
I've ever put on cuz I've been using
them for you Jitsu meaning the undies
calm sensational let's face it you know
how underwear look at your [ __ ]
underwear you know how long you usually
keep your underwear
[ __ ] survey seven years seven years
you know seven you know you're underway
it look like at the [ __ ] seven years
at skidmark skidmark nuts wet on the
side your bust really elastic where you
hit that Whitehead on your ass it pops
people know there's a little red dot on
your ass either you got a needle or you
got a little pimple on your muffler
you'll need for aggravation that's why I
like me on these plus they work for
jiu-jitsu I [ __ ] swear to god they
don't come off people have to put up
with my hairy nut cracking the rash in
my [ __ ]
who needs the aggravation you just going
in to get somebody to [ __ ] arm bar go
to me and these calm before September
1st and get 20% off it'll take a little
mens take a look at the women stands go
to me on these calm I'm not [ __ ]
around which I got em on doctor right
now with this four dudes in the room I
take my underwear out I'm getting beat
up with one of those [ __ ] sticks
what's the code word mister me on these
outcomes last Joey and asked me before
September first so for September first
get 20% off your first order and guess
what they send them right the ass no
more [ __ ] stores no more nothing
these things are fantastic they don't
have to pee hole your little nut sack
right damnation nuts look [ __ ]
tremendous let's give you some extra
protection if somebody takes you with a
facto some karate class somebody thinks
they're cute and they kick you with a
free [ __ ] total in that cycle needs
the aggravation go to me on this comm
get your [ __ ] together now that light
calm nature's box on it press what the
box Church church CH you watch th sleep
and what plans you got for the week I
know you got the wife up at the house
what's going on she's going back
tomorrow you're gonna back tomorrow it's
over yeah no no she's gonna come back
Saturday I don't know right now Mike I
see a movie ursin I don't even know what
to have [ __ ] movies
well you know sex movie about how about
one thought about making a sex move Oh
kind no one's to see that there's no
good angle yet wiggle uncle Joey give me
a little wiggle what stop it with them
is gonna get you really stop you [ __ ]
sexy [ __ ] you True Blood what's
going on baby
we're here are you ready to play some
[ __ ] music what about you they sound
like impromptu in constantly hey don't
just think of Alison chance I'm [ __ ]
when the guy was on heroin with no teeth
he rehearse you can't even go up there
in front [ __ ] - that's true go up
there show you that you got as well
don't have teeth and their [ __ ]
performances Shane MacGowan yeah that's
somebody had one tooth pick from the
pokes no viola was almost done you know
take a chance cuz I'm gonna take that
vote of confidence
yeah we also played the American Legion
over in Hollywood that's a great
building you ever been in there no do
they do comedy in there they would they
have guests they would love to yeah I
got my I got had my wedding party one of
the college's oh those ones above it
early
and then my wife works with a Hollywood
Bowl so come on down I thought you
[ __ ] know what this Hall of Fame [ __ ]
just got the Masters Hall of Fame yeah I
was nominated and it was a good pretty
good group of Filipino martial artists
and that was a big honor was a good time
but I have to say Joey karate one of my
idols I was we used to make sticks and
watch Joey karate on YouTube that was
amazing it was a long time Jesus like
it's still like I still got flexibility
that gets kicks yeah yeah it's gonna
[ __ ] throw him at night just yeah
press and get the blood in it I love it
man I love all that stuff and when I got
away from them wash lunches when I
really [ __ ] up now that I've been back
in it little by little [ __ ] got me
baffled I don't like things that baffle
me it's I come a [ __ ] musician let's
get this out of the way guys I didn't
have the patience or time to get a
guitar and go to the third floor every
week and sit with some time for six
months
then go on my own it's my dream yeah I
got into this because hey once I heard
the song means the same there ain't no
turning back I was at Gunther Brown's
house get some chick that I only suck
your dick on a toilet
do you offered me a little hair when I
was 16 I swear to god he put on no cord
I thought it was all over but the
shouting
I joined pastoral music and I joined the
bass program did that for about three
months and the patient's that's my
musicians plural you say I wanted you to
know I didn't I put the violin in the
first grade with Jesus for one year I
was terrible
and then I tried to do I tried to learn
a guitar but my fingers were too short
intended at all it's apprentice you
gotta play some [ __ ] moves let's do
it yeah
let's jam this [ __ ] out I'm
really high okay we got to turn the [ __ ]
around release I have more people with
us to help us
how about
little music you just killin times and
we're ready
we're just [ __ ] around just listen to
some music
sit back to the [ __ ] it's nice thank you
for listening
sorry [ __ ] around wiped up dummy bad
William that's what the gummies were I
am bears
Caffe I'm Friday night 8 o'clock I guess
let's do this [ __ ] huh let's do this oh
[ __ ] well I'm at the Lord Jesus and he
showed me both his feet he said you sit
upon the ground kid and I'll sit up on
the seat selphie up your scrub brush
grab a washing pan get between my toes
kid and I'll tip you if I can
well I commenced to scrub it I'm sweet
Lord Jesus feet
I was knew he was coming but shut this
thing hell with me with his arches pinky
and scaly
that was blisters on his corns then I
looked at my Lord Jesus and saw he was
growing horns
that's how the devil turned my foot
water and whiskey and I can't remember
nothing since that day with that barn
and amber fluid became a leaking on
froms tutsies wept into my water and a
wash my cares away
so arm and arm was Satan
I went stumbling down the street
and I was rolling dice that Jesus Christ
would save a space for me and I've been
cursing all the curing and cradling this
disease that brought me credit cards and
titty bars and bisexuality 1 2 and may
that's half devil turn my foot watered
whiskey and I can't remember nothing
since that day with that burning amber
fluid that came leaking from his to the
trees wept into my water and wash my
[ __ ] cares away
I'm waiting for that black blade not
many joy I hope it was the podcast so
I'm looking at Lee and I know he's
thinking the same thing that that black
leaves regional song that's on here that
one's not on there that's not another
record I have that with my whole band
pill Billie nights but we do that song
no I love the [ __ ] yo that's the hope
at wha that's the backbreaker right
there what's the story what happened Lee
Lee my hometown I definitely like a
[ __ ] movie producer all right like
the fact la hootenanny for coming in
here tonight believe what you have to
squeaking you perform anywhere no all
right good stay home [ __ ] jumping
jacks this week do something I'm gonna
be in Paducah Friday night at some
[ __ ] Cafe etc come on down
I'm doing hard rated show so bring the
kids down
they're [ __ ] confused where's my boys
at have a hootenanny break it down yeah
we're at the federal this weekend yeah
right what time Boulevard at 8:30 9 8 -
yeah at 8:30 to 10:30 11:00
ok the Early Show but we play a long
time yeah and you're upstairs yeah bring
your dancing shoes yeah Lee's gonna go
represent he's wearing a tuxedo looking
shoot me some of those moves
shake he was on America's Got Talent
I believe it all right whoo what I don't
[ __ ] know countdown for the splat
sighs thank on it again
naturebox.com/tyler it life and me
undies calm go over there before
September 1st date 20% all our responses
I love you estate black I was great
weekend thank you gentlemen thank you
sir thank you now that the show's over
remember to go to naturebox calm and
order great tasting healthy snacks at
50% off snack smarter in the new year
with healthy and delicious treats like
everything bagel chips